[Music]
thank you for the introduction yes so
talk about array computing in Python so
you know mainly as an umpire developer
you know starting from numpy but I'll
try to see like you know what else is
there besides numpy you'll start with a
very very short introduction yeah so
I've been contributing to numpy inside
by for about a decade I've also been on
the you know board of non focus for six
years at the start of the the PI data
conference series which partly set up to
support these projects and to grow the
community and since about one month I'm
the director of concert labs which is
basically a startup company that tries
to hire people that work on numpy ipod
jupiter pandas dusk all these kind of
projects that you're probably using so
if you want to contribute to these
projects or you know you want you're
interested in making work on these kind
of open source packages like a job
rather than like I'm gonna try this in
my evening a few times or you work for a
company that relies on these projects
and you know you might want to help them
make make them sustainable grow them
please come talk to me afterwards so
well start about 20 years ago
on 25 by now so python is the you know
the early 90s and pretty soon after you
know numeric got invented so in Americus
the you know the first thing that was
basically an N dimensional array in in
vital and you know then for 80 years not
much happened numeric grew a little bit
and then someone you know wasn't happy
with numeric anymore because it didn't
basically didn't work well for small
arrays so they invented memory that was
faster on small arrays and that's about
when I started using numpy so you saw
this thing like there's numeric there's
number a which they're pretty much the
same for a beginning user which one do I
have to use so luckily someone wrote
numpy at that point to kind of bring
you know back together and then for a
decade like that's that's all we had and
you know there were a few related things
that were invented like Tiano in 2008
for like the first you know deep
learning framework of this kind I think
and then number to speed things up a
little bit but it's really like from the
last three four years that there's kind
of this explosion of you know new
libraries that you know do different
kinds of array computing so if you want
distributed arrays you you know you're
probably using tasks if you're using
deep learning if you're using tensor
flow or pi torch or maybe even a max net
or q pi with chainer and then you have a
new library for sparse arrays and it
kind of goes all over the place so you
know if that keeps on continuing you
know we're all in for a lot of trouble
so I want to talk about you know what
we're as an umpire team trying to do to
kind of you know deal with this
explosion of different libraries that
all don't talk to each other
another question how many of you do deep
learning like a third or so right you
probably have had the problem that you
know you want to do some computer vision
let's say and you know there's just been
a new algorithm like you know faster RC
and then a couple of years ago and it's
it was building cafe right and now all
your other coach isn't tensorflow so do
you switch the cafe do you not use the
algorithm at all like this if there are
all these little silos that don't talk
to each other right so that's a problem
we're trying to solve and and here is
the first example of you know what that
what it can look like so if you have
some code I don't know oh this point
with my head so if you have some code
and you know it just does something
useful right and it uses number
functions right normally you would
expect to feed that numpy race right you
can't feed it like a tensor flow array
so if we if we time that like this
little function takes 21 milliseconds
so now I make a new array of Koopa so
Koopa is basically numpy for GPUs
there's a couple of those like my torch
is very similar but cuba is the most
like a standalone library about the size
of an empire with almost an identical
API so this now is living on my NVIDIA
GPU and I can now feed it into this same
function and all of a sudden at six
times faster that's kind of nice because
I didn't have to change my function but
this this wasn't really possible until
today so I'm gonna explain you after
like how this actually works and then
you know how you can start using it
here's another one so if you use task
right task is this library that
basically provides you an array but
under the hood it's like a collection
that can live in on different machines
and that transparently like distributes
your data over different machines so you
can do things at a really large scale
but normally you would have to adapt all
your code you know because you start
with a small data sample you know your
billet and numpy and then you have to
rewrite all your code to used articles
but what you see here is you know some
linear algebra right you just feed it in
the array and you get you know some
arrays Q and R back to do some QR
decomposition now if you if you do that
with tasks normally you would have to
find the task equivalent that does QR
decomposition but now in this example
you can just use the numpy function and
in the end you still get your deskaway
back I guess so just wanna point out you
you should try this at home or here and
it seems like we have good Wi-Fi so this
is this will this will download quite a
few quite a few packages if you just
want to try this works the same and pip
if your app user but I assume most
people use Conda I just installed the
latest versions of numpy tasks and
Jupiter lab and then if you have a GPU
on your computer you want to install a Q
PI in this case
it's only support I just showed you is
only supported in cube by 6 which will
come out like next month or so but you
can install it with this command so the
first release candidate is out and then
the last important thing is in number 5
1.16 all of this works and that's the
current version of numpy but you have to
set this experiment at this environment
variable before you start so it will
become default in a future version
probably in about 2 months or so but if
you want to try it today you have to set
this ok so what do we actually want to
achieve with it with this whole exercise
we wanted to take the numpy api and kind
of separate it from the rest of numpy
from let's call it the execution engine
so you can call an umpire function and
then basically route it to Tantra flow
PI torch or q pi or whatever because
what these libraries do you know have
done already is basically they looked at
numpy said huh that's kind of nice but I
want it on a GPU or something so they
just copied the API and then made some
slight changes and and then you know now
I have a duplicate right and we actually
have five or six duplicates today so we
wanted to give them a an option and
future libraries that come along to say
like hey I don't need to just copy paste
this whole API and I reimplemented just
I can use this API and just plug into it
and that will help because right now we
have like you know all these array
libraries but we only have one side PI
and we have you know once I could learn
right and if we don't do anything like
in two years we may have you know side
by four tensorflow and they have side by
4 PI torch and then it will come you
know everything it takes five times more
effort so we basically want to go from
this where you have all these libraries
that consumer raised and that basically
have to like use each individual one to
this situation where it just talked to
numb pine you can still talk direct but
you can just talk to numpy and then go
to the library that you want
all right so how does that'll work I
gave a start start simple with a single
I'll talk about a single function
because most of most of numpy and most
of you know data science is just using
functions so if you look at a function
you have a signature and a function body
right signature is just this one line
that defines your function and it has a
number of parameters and keywords right
and the function body is everything else
right and that everything else just
doesn't doesn't tell you what you can
feed in that's the signature but it
tells you how it then behaves right so
and for numpy these can be two types of
functions like the distinction usually
doesn't matter to you as a user but yeah
you know there's these thing calls you
you funks or universal functions those
are the ones that have that are all look
the same to have an act D type an out
argument and you know they kind of built
with standard machinery and everything
that's not a you func is like usually
all slightly different because it
doesn't fit nicely in the universal
function pattern so for both of these
types of functions this this works now
and before it used to work only for you
folks because it was much easier with
this you know standard patro so what we
do now is we basically separated the
function signature from the function
body so we kind of copy it over
conceptually and then we kind of check
the input arguments so if the first
argument to a function is an array then
we check if it has this array function
attribute right and if it does you know
we basically hand over execution of
everything to whatever is in in that
array function attribute right so if
you're now Q PI or tensorflow
you know you can just add to your own
tensor or n dimensional array object
this array function thing and then say
like you know just use my implementation
right so it allows you to replace the
whole implementation of vampire
Jeron so at the moment this works for
all functions and it works for an the
array method so if you have code that
just uses that you're basically good to
go today if you have like complicated
like classes or decorators or something
that are really numpy those are those
you can't yet overwrite so there she
would then still have to use from the
actual library you want to be executing
your code with all right let's see if we
can switch to a notebook
this is readable no way
is it readable like this no that's good
okay all right
so as import some things and just tell
us what version it is I'll publish this
later by the way so I'll put my slice I
assumed it you're distributing all the
slides right yes
okay so this is the example I showed you
and so let's go and explain that so
let's not go through that quickly
and first of all I'll show you how to
check if this actually works for a
particular function so just use the
double question mark to show the source
code easiest way to show the source code
so here you see this signature right and
the line above it it says array function
dispatch right that means it's
implemented and the way this this
function signature copying working works
it's with this one decorator so if you'd
be writing your own library you want to
be using that thank you right there
write that so now I wanted to try that
on just some function that I wrote
because you know that's in the end you
know what what you're probably most
interested in so I took a function from
from side by that I was familiar with
and that's just a
pull function doing a t-test and I first
just copy the thing as is and the only
line I copied out I commented out was
this one that the as array one because
what that does and you'll see that in
most functions probably not in your own
code but in library code but it checks
if something is is a numpy array if it's
not it it converts it into one yeah that
kind of defeats the whole purpose right
yes so I copied that one I commented
that one out but the rest is all the
same so this is basically what you'll
find in sight by as well but it's it's
standard code that does some you know it
does some checks for Nan's
it calculates the mean you know variance
square root and then in the end it you
know uses some distribution to calculate
the actual statistic we're interested in
and I inserted one thing I inserted here
was a print to check that you know we're
actually getting you know for feeding an
umpire way we get an umpire array at the
end and if we feed in a task right we
got a task radiant so you know here we
just create some random numbers you know
so 100 random numbers feed them you know
split them into two columns so we
compare a column a with column B right
and then we do a t-test on that and then
we get some result that says if we get a
p-value here it's not really interesting
what the p-value is but you get some
value out so now we do that same thing
for desk all right so here will tell you
now you got a desk right that's what we
printed and okay so it kind of works but
you know there's one tricky bit with
tasks it looks a bit weird so if you
look at the statistic here it tells you
the stored away with something blah blah
but if you if you read the whole thing
there's no actual values because you
have to remember a task is kind of this
distributed distributed array object and
it you know it kind of builds up a graph
of what you want to do and it only
executes it when you tell it to so at
the end to make this work we have to do
one thing that's specific to dusk and
say like a compute me this result
actually so if you get if you just print
the statistic right it just say the end
result will be a task array but it
doesn't tell you what's in it so now if
we ask it to actually compute then you
get the values right so this is still
fairly new and it won't work for
everything but it will work like for a
lot of your code if you know if you're
just using regular functions and not too
many magical magical things all right so
there are some limits sure you know
small example here of something that
does not work so for example this numpy
dot air earth state right it's checks
for invalid so I tell it here like if
you see an invalid like an an or a nymph
right
raise an error so if you feed in like an
umpire array that has an an in it
because I just explicitly put one in
here right I get an error as I expect
because that's what I asked it to do now
if you do the same for q pi right
there's also an an in here but if I ask
you to do something useful like it
doesn't raise an error it just gives me
the nav back right and that's because
this earth did that is not in Q PI right
it hasn't been overridden
so you have to be a little bit careful
still and we're at the moment talking
about ways of like making this more
comprehensive but you know for really
special objects it's kind of hard to
override them because the idea is you
know we override them by I give you an
array and I check if the array has an
array function thing you know attribute
attached to it but you know in this in
this case this MP dot earth state there
is no input so there is nothing to check
right so we just need a different
mechanism to
overriding that so the most important
exceptions that don't work that you may
be using a lot are the array creation
functions if you have in the code that
you write something that says oh NP dot
array you know and then a list of values
or something right that explicitly says
like you know I'm constructing a numpy
array right you can't check those
individual values and say like oh you
know you meant a cube array or a part
torturer right here and so if you have a
right you know creating arrays you want
to separate those out of your function
and the function itself should just have
your what's called your business logic
okay so that I think is the the single
most important change we made in lump I
over the past three years or so so we we
now have actually for the first time in
ever like we now have a few people that
are paid to work on numpy because we got
a grant from the Moore Foundation I sort
more in Sloan so we have three engineers
working on by now so there's a lot more
interesting features coming hopefully so
these are kind of at a high level what
we're planning to do so the
interoperability there so I call this a
red function interoperability you know
we can now work better with you know all
these GPU objects and these distributed
arrays so there will be there would be
more of that so it becomes more complete
and more robust because right now like
we've basically just released it and
yeah maybe you can start using it
tomorrow but there's not much code out
there and other library steps using this
then extensibility so it's very hard to
make custom D types everything is nice
if you have this normal floats and int
and maybe date times right but if you
want to add like missing data support or
you want to have a race with units
that's a very popular one there are like
10 different libraries that make a race
with units so if you you know multiply
meters by seconds then you know its
meter second and if that's not what you
wanted to get you know consistency
checks that raise a flag that that works
today but it's extremely hard so that
there's an example of a thing called
quaternions which is kind of a rotation
matrix I just looked at it as 1600 lines
of C code to make it the D type that's a
quaternion right and it should be like
an you know maybe a hundred lines of
code then performance we haven't done a
whole lot on performance I mean it's
fast compared to Python but you know
compared to number and you know at some
of the newer things that have come in
and it's starting to get slightly slower
and more performance is always helpful
right that's why we like GPUs in the
first place so there will be you Frank
optimizations to basically make every
every function and numpy have less
overhead and make it faster there we
vector instructions so if you have very
large arrays you know the CPU has
special instructions to process them in
batches so we have some support for
those but it's incomplete at the moment
so if you're on Linux and with GCC then
you know it's a lot faster than if
you're on some exotic platform at a
compiler that's not ECC and so it's
shouldn't be too hard to make that more
complete so that's that's in the
pipeline as well then random number
generation there's a whole rewrite
that's going to be that's about to be
merged so that whole module is new it
won't break your existing code but
there's a lot more options for faster
sampler samplers with more you know but
longer quasi periodicity then indexing
there will be new indexing behavior if
you used x-ray that has in some cases
more intuitive indexing so if you give
it let's say you know one two three and
you know one five seven it gives you
like this well let's call it I don't
have to call it but basically it's more
intuitive to see which elements will get
selected while this fancy 'm indexing in
numpy it's often like a bit
counterintuitive so add a new indexing
indexing mode basically
and then last one is type annotations so
that's going a bit slower it's not the
highest priority but it's nice to have
for like understanding your code better
and a bunch of other purposes okay so
let's see how much time do I have eight
minutes okay so that was kind of an a
brief overview of what's in numpy and
you know I'll also give an overview of
what might be coming you know in the
next few years because it's actually
actually interesting like numpy is like
you know almost almost everybody here
uses it at some point but it's like
because it's so old and it has such a
large user base it's kind of hard to
evolve so we don't know what's gonna
happen in a few years we're gonna keep
pushing them forward but I've also been
new new options alright so I just
there's no good way I tried this for a
really long time this slide there's no
good way to put like all of these array
libraries honest and on to on the
two-dimensional picture right because
some are really big some focus on
performance some focus on new you know
new features like you know better
missing data support like like R has but
the axes are chose here our maturity and
then I divided in GP or CPU or both and
then I've put in data frames as well
maturity is kind of interesting because
this is one of the first thing I think
you should look at if you keep trying to
use something new if you want to live on
the bleeding edge and see you know what
everybody else will be using in five
years you know you want it you want to
probably here somewhere and if you just
want goat that words you know you want
to be on this end
and then I put a few things in gray and
I'll I'll give a few like you array I'll
talk about that in last slides
intentially those are not really array
objects but they're kind of interfaces
to them and the same for arrow in terms
of data frames like you've got pandas
you know you got like the GPU version of
pandas an arrow is kind of this
interchange format that makes things
work together better all right so the
first one I'll talk about it X and D
that says the library that's about
started two years ago with the idea to
take all the concepts of numpy and
create them as a number of individual
libraries so it's all more modular it's
very you know for clean new C code so
there's three libraries basically one
for an array container object one for
the actual data types and a third one
how do you make functions on top of
those two things so it basically it's
it's still you know very young so it
might be not future completely other
places but it it's in terms of
performance and features very similar to
numpy at the time and then it has a
whole bunch of things that we always
wanted in numpy but you know we're
always too hard to build like variable
length strings if you work with strings
you probably have noticed that it you
know those are really annoying to work
with because there are no real variable
length strings so if you take a sentence
and you break it up into words and you
want to put them in an array right you
have to make the data type of the array
as long as the longest word that you
have and then when you encounter or
longer word later it doesn't fit and all
your code breaks all right so
accidentally has proper variable length
strings which means you know it's easier
to work with and it fits in less memory
so you can work with bigger data then
ragged arrays same thing for you know if
you have something that's not nicely
Square so it fits in an umpire error
data frame but it has various various
lengths that's called ragged arrays and
has support for that and a few more
things like you know easier d types it's
automatic multi-threading which numpy
doesn't have no part if you install from
anaconda you do get a non-pilot mkl you
know
things run on all the all the course
that you have but but if you just
install an umpire whip it you just get
your single core by default and you have
to really try to paralyze it so
automatic multi-threading is nice if you
do a plus B you know endurance as fast
as it can on all the hardware that you
have and then it also has yet
compilation just like just like number
via number so a brief example of that so
variable length strength so it's like
this is a test notebook it tells you it
at the type is string and you know it
has five elements basically right well
if you do this in numpy it's it tells
you you know you so I guess for down
here Unicode of length 8 because there's
notebook is the longest word so you know
it needs eight characters and now you
know all of this this a you know it's
one character but it also takes up the
same space as the word notebook and the
same for ragged arrays like you know you
see like in this case you get type of
fare so variable lengths basically well
in numpy if you try this it kind of eats
it but it transfers everything to an
object and that's basically fairly
useless it's like it's it's in an array
but I don't know what it is basically
it's like it's just the reference to
some object and and you can't really
process it very well all right next
array library is extensor this is a very
interesting one especially if you're a
C++ developer so they took all the
concepts of numpy like broadcasting and
indexing and put them into C++ and then
focused on performance and reusability
so and it's really fast it has lazy
evaluations there are some problems
where it's like you know the fastest
thing out there it can operate on Empire
is you know from C++ without doing any
copying and it has fight and Julian are
bindings so if you if your company and
you want to ship your algorithm and you
we use it in Python and in R or button
and in Julia or all three right the idea
is you write it with extensors and C++
so you get nice array semantics I don't
have to use just only the standard
built-in you know it things like
broadcasting are really nice it didn't
exist in C++ C++ before but then
basically you write it once and you can
get it into all of Python Julie and are
it also has yet compilation not file
number but firefighter and it's just you
know comparable in terms of performance
and then I just noticed last month
that's our and now has this project
called RA where some guy thought like
okay you know I'm gonna get stuck with
or I don't really like all right now it
doesn't really have good arrays now they
have known PI like arrays in R so if
you're an hour user he like check that
out are we ah yes
okay so I'll skip this example but go to
the extensor website you can you can use
C++ interactively in the Jupiter
notebook and last I'll leave this up you
array is basically a generalization of
the array protocols that I talked about
so that's that's still a very young
project but that will allow you to
override things like decorators and
classes and whatever you want all right
thank you very much
[Applause]